3,5 години роботи швеї йде на те, щоб пошити ось такий комплект одягу.
Ми дуже довго йшли до того, щоб вийти на ту якість, яка є зараз.
Ну ось, бачите, у нас тут їх лежить дуже багато.
Підприємець Дмитро Довгалюк демонструє набір дитячого одягу,
який разом з іншою білизною, іграшками та засобами гігієни
для новонароджених та породіль його компанія комплектувала до великої коробки
та півтора року доставляла в усі куточки України.
Таким бейбі-боксом держава з вересня 2018 року забезпечувала українські сім’ї,
в яких народився малюк. Нині на складах підприємця лежать тисячі упаковок
загальною вартістю понад 15 млн гривень. Що робити з ними далі,
Дмитро Довгалюк поки не знає, адже уряд саме ухвалив рішення
замінити бейбі-бокси з товарами на грошову допомогу родинам.
Кошти надходитимуть батькам на спеціальну картку вже з 1 вересня.
Однак міністерство соціальної політики планує визначити,
на що саме та в яких магазинах родини зможуть їх витратити.
Батьки дитини можуть звернутися за компенсацією протягом 12 місяців
з дати народження дитини та самостійно протягом року
витратити кошти грошової компенсації виключно для придбання дитині одягу, взуття,
засобів гігієни та догляду, текстилю, іграшок, засобів гігієни для породіллі.
Катерина Будніченко, мама 7-місячного Кирила, переконана, що
гроші на перші потреби малюкам - це добре, однак бейбі-бокс - значно краще.
Родина особливо відчула переваги готового набору, адже перші місяці життя сина
прийшлися на карантин, коли дитячі магазини не працювали,
а доставка товарів з-закордону затримувалася.
Коробка класна, щільна, ми використовуємо її для іграшок.
Отримавши бейбі-бокс, я подивилася і подумала: о, ми, наприклад,
могли б це купити кращої якості чи те, з одного боку,
а як наслідок ми потім усім користувалися, навіть тими іграшками,
які не треба стерилізувати. Дитині вони сподобалися.
Але я б хотіла відзначити, що багато людей у нас живуть в селах, в маленьких містечках,
де прибутки, відверто кажучи, менші. Тому цей бейбі-бокс має певні огріхи,
але загалом укомплектований непогано, дуже непогано.
Коли пакунки малюка тільки з’явилися у 2018 році, вони містили близько 30 предметів.
Відтоді вміст коробки переглядався 4 рази, якість і кількість товарів зростала.
Остання версія пакунку, який породіллі досі отримують в деяких регіонах,
складається з понад 60 одиниць одягу, білизни, іграшок і засобів гігієни для малюка і мами.
Опитування міжнародного фонду UNICEF показали, що на початку дії
програми державної підтримки сімей 35% були задоволені пакунками малюка.
Решта воліли б отримати грошову компенсацію.
У 2020 вже 80% батьків, маючи вибір, надали б перевагу коробці з товарами.
Одразу коли дитина народжується, в тебе немає часу бігати по магазинах і все вибирати.
В принципі, набір досить адекватний, крім деяких пунктів.
Але я був задоволений абсолютно. Мені було набагато менше клопоту
саме з цим бейбі-боксом, ніж було б з грошовою компенсацією.
Гроші - це є гроші. І ти їх, можливо, навіть витратиш не на дитину.
А от бейбібоксом ми користувалися усім, що там було.
Наприклад, якщо люди у містах можуть це собі дозволити,
піти по магазинах з дитиною, то в селах немає де їх витрачати,
немає як, особливо зараз, під час карантину.
Можливо, сім’ям, які неблагополучні, то краще би бейбі-бокс отримували.
Як на мене, я би взяла 5 тисяч гривень і потратила на речі кращої якості.
На першому етапі важко зрозуміти, що треба, де його купити,
яке саме його купити. А тут ти відкрив, взяв готове,
наприклад, соску якусь чи іншу штуку, і користуєшся.
У міжнародному дитячому фонді ЮНІСЕФ, який брав активну участь
у запровадженні програми "Пакунок малюка" та в постійному вдосконаленні вмісту бейбі-боксу,
вже закликали уряд повернути цю державну ініціативу допомоги родинам.
Тут наголошують: у порівнянні з грошовою компенсацією
пакунки мають низку вагомих переваг.
Пакунок, основна його ідея - це не надати якусь грошову чи іншу допомогу.
Основна його ідея - це виховання позитивного батьківства, тобто розвинути ті навички,
правильні навички виховання дитини, які потрібні для її правильного розвитку.
Пакунок маляти надає рівні права і можливості незалежно від її соціально-економічного статусу.
По-друге, там були також вкладені інформаційні матеріали
щодо правильного та позитивного виховання дитини,
зокрема щодо вакцинації та грудного вигодовування.
Окрім підтримки родин, бейбі-бокси, яких щорічно виготовляли близько трьохсот тисяч,
були неабияким стимулом для українського бізнесу,
адже за два роки частка вітчизняних товарів у кожній коробці зросла з 15 до 50 одиниць.
Їх виготовляли майже 40 підприємств в різних регіонах України.
За підрахунками бізнесмена і президента Всеукраїнського об’єднання
роботодавців легкої промисловості Олександра Соколовського,
після відміни урядом пакунків малюка галузь може втрати майже 1000 робочих місць.
Окрім того, Соколовський вважає, що на заміну українським речам
з бейбі-боксу прийдуть китайські чи турецькі в магазинах,
а їхню якість ніхто не контролюватиме. Відтак єдиною причиною для уряду
відмовитися від бейбі-боксів Соколовський вважає корупцію.
Державний бюджет замість того, щоб витратити 3800 гривень, вони витратять 5000 гривень.
І на сумі 1 млрд 200 млн - це ще десь 350 млн гривень прямих втрат для бюджету.
Тобто хтось десь у кабінетних кулуарах придумав цю схему,
щоб вкрасти гроші з бюджету - це 350 млн додаткових коштів, -
і вкрасти в молодих батьків на різниці між гуртовими і роздрібними цінами.
Тобто заробить якась роздрібна мережа. А роздрібній мережі не проблема
додати 10% до своєї націнки і ці 10% дати як "відкат" тим чиновникам, які допомогли.
Однією з причин заміни пакунку малюка на грошову компенсацію
в уряді називають провал тендеру на формування та доставку коробок.
Раніше його організовувало управління ООН по обслуговуванню проектів ЮНОПС.
Тепер цим займається державна установа "Професійні закупівлі".
Під час проведення останнього тендеру вона нібито помітила ознаки змови
декількох учасників і звернулася до Анитмонопольного комітету України.
Водночас дискваліфіковані учасники так само подали скаргу
через їх виключення з процедури, тому на час розслідування тендер зупинили.
Фахівчиня платформи з публічних закупівель каже, що не вбачає жодних порушень
в самій процедурі проведення торгів, однак через бюрократичні нюанси
наступний тендер може відбутися не скоро.
Треба місяць на розробку тендерної документації, місяць на подачу тендерних пропозицій,
20 днів замовнику на розгляд тендерних пропозицій,
потім на аукціон, тобто це може затягнутися приблизно на 4 місяці.
Тому зараз, наскільки я розумію, уряд шукає будь-які альтернативи,
щоб хоча б на певний час задовільнити потреби породіль.
Я думаю, що це пов’язано з тим, що просто немає часу зараз на проведення нової процедури.
Якщо уряд вирішить залишити допомогу батькам у вигляді 5000 гривень,
підприємець Дмитро Довгалюк планує розформувати комплекти
і передати їх у реалізацію магазинам.
Втім, якщо нині собівартість пакунку складає 3800 грн., то, за підрахунками
міжнародного фонду ЮНІСЕФ, купуючи ті самі товари окремо в магазинах,
батьки сплатять щонайменше 7 тисяч гривень.